IT'S NOW TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: BECAUSE MONDAYS
ALWAYS RUIN YOUR WEEKEND, WE'RE
RETURNING TO OUR TRADITION
OF A #RUINAMONDAY HASHTAG.
SO TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#RUINAMOVIEQUOTE.
EXAMPLES MIGHT BE, "LUKE, I AM
YOUR FACEBOOK FRIEND, OR "YOU
CAN'T HANDLE THE SHIA LABEOUF,"
OR "NOBODY PUTS BABY IN A
DUMPSTER."
THOSE ARE WAYS YOU CAN RUIN A
MOVIE QUOTE.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
I'M SAYING NOBODY DOES THAT.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK STARTING NOW, AND GO.
BRAUNGER.
>> I LOVE THE SMELL OF NATHAN
IN THE MORNING.
>> Chris: IS THAT FROM TUXEDO
GUYS?
>> WE ACTUALLY TOOK THAT FROM
TUXEDO GUYS.
>> Chris: NICE, POINTS.
MARK NORMAND.
>> HERE'S LOOKING AT YOU,
KIDDIE PORN.
>> Chris: THAT WOULD RUIN THAT
MOVIE QUOTE, POINTS.
SARA SCHAEFER.
>> I'LL BE NICKELBACK.
>> Chris: BUT YOU HAVE TO SAY IT
LIKE SCHWARZENEGGER.
>> (DEEP VOICE): I'LL BE
NICKELBACK.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS, WELL
DONE.
NICE TERMINATOR.
MARK NORMAND.
>> Chris: MY SON WILL COME OUT
TOMORROW.
>> Chris: NICE, OKAY.
SURE, POINTS.
BRAUNGER.
>> THE FIRST RULE OF FIGHT CLUB
IS "MEOW MEOW MEOW, KITTY
KITTY."
>> Chris: WHY COULDN'T THAT HAVE
BEEN THE FIRST RULE OF FIGHT
CLUB?
OH, YES, POINTS.
MARK NORMAND.
>> THIS ONE TIME AT
CONCENTRATION CAMP...
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
>> Chris: IS THAT FROM THE
MOVIE "GERMAN PIE?"
(LAUGHING)
POINTS.
BRAUNGER.
>> YOU HAD ME AT "BIG BOOTY HOS
HUMP WITH IT."
>> Chris: POINTS.
SARA.
>> IF YOU SHAVE IT, HE WILL
COME.
(APPLAUSE)